jour 8 de la campagne électorale ou
l'art de bien choisir ses éléments de
langage calembours du chef de la caq sur
le remboursement des lunettes
on pourrait poser qu'est la cac n'a pas
de vision mais ça ne dépendra pas trop
l'atmosphère c'est la sphère du prêt
d'éric caire qui revient sans cesse
cette histoire là commence à vous en ce
et la ligne de défense
c'est l'amitié c'est pas de l'argent
public lassé d'un ami qui prêtent de
l'argent à un ami une question d'amitié
avec proximité d'un ami à un ami
apparence de confiner une différence
entre être dans l'opposition puis est au
gouvernement si vous un ami vous prêtent
l'argent on est justement au fait madame
bourdon est ce que vous feriez 4-1 la
révolution ah oui deux choses à noter
dans les secondes qui suivent le choix
du temps de verbe et les têtes qui
démangent
au même moment ils vont avoir la vie
dure non mais à part ça c'est gérard
livres pour le non mais non ces semaines
auront travail de scénarios rudement
epoté de s'écrire mais revenons à la cac
encore une fois parce qu'on est dans un
château de 20 chevaux ska si mathieu
prost radio canada non
[Musique]